Eric Voss here with the new rockstars  hot take about Loki season 2. new  footage shows Sylvie in a 70s record  store with his peculiar monkey toy  behind her I looked this up it's  actually a vintage toy from Japanese toy  maker Alps batteries go in the stereo  drawer and this monkey strums the guitar  he rocks his head back and forth he Taps  his little orange shoes normally he has  a green Sombrero that comes with them  but you know hats off and go missing  from collector's items we saw that with  Woody  so this would be an incredibly rare and  really weird thing for Sylvie to have  with her maybe it was an item that she  took with her during her youth hopping  from apocalyptic event to apocalyptic  event and that's why this monkey is gray  and so worn down despite just being only  20 years old or so Sylvie has her toy  monkey to keep her company just like the  way Kang and he remains created Miss  minutes to keep him company hey y'all